we love the show that's Monday nights at
9:00 Eastern on AMC it is the red hot
better call Saul and the only thing
perhaps more dramatic than this man's
characters last hour of television as
Howard Hamlin could be his beloved Penn
State University sweating out against
Appalachian State or Lincoln or his
beloved Steelers waiting for Le'Veon
Bell to walk in front or Patrick Fabian
good to see you both of those things
hang heavy that I tell you what an
exciting opening weekend there's no
doubt about it but Appalachian State Hey
look aye sir you see the helmet that's
on the desk oh I know you so you you
know where you speak there's no doubt
about it
Oh Appalachian State I was with all due
respect to you and the we are nation yes
um I was ready for misery to have
company I was quite ready but that kid
McSorley's got a set of stones and and
man they they they're opportunistic they
make big plays tres is fantastic and
like you said he's got stones and also I
believe they were starting like eight
freshmen or eight first-timers and they
just they got skittish they got they got
nervous you could see it you can see it
in their play but they stuck it together
I think that's a great crucible for the
whole season that that game run it helps
to emerge victorious from I mean man I I
don't want to wear it put my misery on
you there but look you guys get to own
that all by yourself though that's kind
of nice okay no that's it is not nice
it's the opposite of nice it's dreadful
and I was ready to have the the the
company but when you were on campus they
they won they were undefeated right were
you on campus I was when I graduated so
that was less than we had the
championship yeah it was amazing I mean
there's Miami and the Fiesta ball yeah I
mean and that was that whole you know
the camo thing and all that stuff and
you know I was a theater major in
college so I was that was my fraternity
was doing the arts arts and crafts thing
right and and yet going to a big
University like that allowed you to have
that experience as well so you know
Saturday game days there was nothing
like it I still get chills because of
them holes you're chillin it's one of
the best things in the world going to
that thing you know with the the leaves
coming down the people streaming out to
the stage
in watching come on the field I had a
really wonderful time doing it so I mean
the the the arts program there if I'm
not mistaken Michael key yes right is it
an alum there is ty burrell an alum that
know he went to Oregon who else who else
has gone to that there's a tie because I
wanted to say ty is from there but I
think he might have done this yeah I
believe so as well they were um well
after me they were after before that
before that before them but they're you
know there's a lot of folks out here or
love their Penn State football and now
what where do you Patrick Fabian a
better call Saul here on the Rich Eisen
show before we start geeking out on the
show with you Todd Burrell is Penn State
yes okay yes all right so what do you
stand and you're Steeler friends stand
on what's going on with Le'Veon Bell
Bolivia you know when when the o-line
starts coming out against you you've got
problems I mean I want them back
obviously I want them back their record
of just reading this other day when when
the big three played there like 39 and
17 and when one of them is missing
they're like I don't know 14 and 10
mm-hmm so it's imperative these back
however at this point psychologically
you're like what kind of damage is he
already doing to the team I don't know
the business of it so I don't know what
the end game is other than more money or
more money now but I doesn't sound like
that's gonna be happening I mean maybe a
trade I don't know there do there's I
don't know
stranger things have happened like like
one of the top pass rushers in the game
in Khalil Mack getting traded a week
before the season nice that's you never
for two first-round picks you never see
something like that so maybe he's
sitting near thinking if I hold out week
one my guys will still handle the Browns
mm-hmm I can come back and still like
last year missed one game and I still
led the league in every damn thing right
I could still do that I saved my body
for a week that's what it is
maybe that's I don't I honestly don't
know but clearly he told the linemen
something and then not showing up pissed
him off or something was going on
between him and his linemen in the past
that this pisses them off I don't know
it really is a total mystery patch dude
you better have a fantastic
right everyone's gonna have to pick
themselves up around that you know and I
or James Connor who everyone knows in
town anyway because he's from you know
he's a Pittsburgh guy right so he might
he might take that moment in time I mean
the thing is you know Le'Veon is such a
unique athlete right so you want to use
the gloves to keep him there but at some
point at some point if it's gonna ruin
the franchise it's a team sport still
right it still is a team sport so
they're all saying that's what the
linemen are saying and I love Tomlin too
by the way I don't understand Steeler
fans who have a problem with him how can
you have a problem with that guy my wife
has a crush on him she's like look if my
calls I'm leaving get it better call
Mike or Mike better not call whatever
you want to say
better call Saul Mondays at 9:00 Eastern
Time on AMC all right we were talking in
our eyes an overtime segment yesterday
about the opening scene Friday from last
week's episode last week's episode where
he's playing Saul Goodman for I think
kind of the first time because the only
other times when he appears as in a way
Saul Goodman he's kind of Jimmy Jimmy
McGill post Breaking Bad in the middle
of the country so he sees he saw Brice
now Jean but we don't see the Frye he's
on the run color of this is kind of the
first time in better call Saul we have
seen him as Saul Goodman I believe it's
also the first time we've opened like a
show that's in in the in-between time
right we've got the gene on the other
end of Breaking Bad and then this is
actually it this is like finding a lost
scene a Breaking Bad and that you were
talking the other day in the overtime
about the episode it would be Granite
State which is the episode that he would
be a rock when you were wondering like
reading recaps and there someone said I
think was Alan Sepinwall said it was
between Ozymandias and Grand that's sort
of when that that moment happens you
know because we don't ever see him
bug out bug out danik punched the walls
find the cache which is so saddest I'm
making a call he made the call right he
made the call you know it's so good and
Fran I mean that whole scene for me
works when he puts his arms out to get a
hug from Francesca she just turned his
nothing right but for me as a fan I'm
wondering you know I want I so want more
of that you know and the question is is
why I just did is that just like a piece
of red meat firm do you have a to the
fans who want more that or do you ever
have a conversation with the the makers
of the show about this sort of thing you
know I think the whole the whole show is
predicated on the idea that we know
where we're going so we're watching the
slow motion car crash basically because
as you sort of like Jimmy McGill you
really she's not gonna stay that way but
you still want to see Saul because Saul
was great in Breaking Bad but now we see
what he is losing as he goes there it's
like I think there's a lot of sentiment
for like Oh Kent Kim Wexler can't they
go somewhere yeah can't they go
somewhere and just have a good life as
opposed to what's going to happen but
you know the episode was called quite a
ride written by an Turkish and you know
when he says that quite a ride we know
what that ride is and I think that's the
deliciousness of sort of watching what's
gonna happen next and I was telling you
off-camera and all I'll say here Patrick
Fabian of better call Saul playing
Howard Hamlin here on the Rich Eisen
show is that you know I talked about
this with my wife as I'm watching the
show whether we're locked into better
call Saul is that the movie miracle is
one of my favorite sports movies
I know Team USA is going to win the gold
medal and yet I'm on the edge of my seat
right the entire time I know your
character Howard and as you mentioned
Kim West Wexler right you're the only
characters I think on the show that are
I know are not going to be killed by
Walter White spoiler alert
maybe not killed maybe we go to the
Caribbean Kim and I open episode I don't
know law firm we sailor on the Caribbean
it's called thongs or us watching it
don't it's so crazy because we know
we're saw a Jimmy saw go right but don't
you want Jimmy to be good and end up
with him and they have a great life
together well there's there's some fan
theories out there that say that does
happen but it happens in Omaha in the
back end maybe it happens in the back
end you know you you've seem very
gleeful about my death at the hands of
Walter White but
maybe I don't know if you something else
happens I mean we don't know it could be
even more sad we're you know I just sort
of drift away as life happens right the
writers I'm not Kiedis into what may be
going on I know that Rhea seehorn who
plays Kim Wexler and I will whenever we
get a script we immediately and then
call each other like alive again for one
more week
it's true because we don't know you know
you know Jonathan banks I talked to him
one time about you know how excited I
was that we got picked up for season
three and everything else I called him I
called him like we had made the JV
cheerleading squad like Jonathan we got
picked up and and he goes that's nice
Patrick but let me remind you we know
that I make it to Breaking Bad we know
Bobby makes it to Breaking Bad you see
on mando we don't know what happens to
you
his final capital was this save you
money yeah oh that is great because we
had Giancarlo Esposito in studio a
couple weeks ago and he said the scene
where he tells the Michael mando
character you are mine and he said he
did it in one take he said that it was a
very edgy night on the set yes so I
heard if you've noticed my suit doesn't
show up in those dirty dirty places I
know they see a white collar your white
collar guy but I heard there was I heard
there was some tension does that happen
all in good tension well you know what
we're all working hard and it gets late
it's it's nighttime it's dark and those
guys are also mining some really dark
emotions so I would be curious to be a
fly on the wall for a lot of those like
that all right before before I let you
go sir you you did what did you do yeah
first of all this is the camera for the
NFL the NFL camera the NFL I was not I
was not sent to Vegas to do anything
other than enjoy the mermaid show at the
Silverton casino by the way which is a
very nice thing if you have children
however I didn't make some bets on
behalf of some of the gentlemen here
here and they give you a handy-dandy
envelope to send your winning booklets
back I've got some for you guys too
thank you is getting it done oh my god
these are actual really betting tickets
thank you Mike instead of accepting your
tickets won't you turn his microphone on
while he's walking around the studio
space there we go so so so the tickets
are three in there one I made this the
one for you
that first ticket was before the game
and I may have gouged you by making the
bed I'm sorry for that yeah it's it's a
Michigan outright to win the college
football playoff yeah and then the
second one is your long shot in the NFL
because you never you never know $5.00
bet on the Browns to a Super Bowl
Patriots outright outright winner and
then so we can all set a 5-2 win three
is that what that is
5-2 win 30 okay and then finally so you
can feel like winners I gave you the
winning ticket for the Super Bowl
Pittsburgh Steelers at the end of the
season and they'll mail you your money
isn't that nice did you get the same
thing Mike - I feel like I should pay
you back I should feel like that this
this is an act this actually cost
better call solve dollars you know what
is my gift to you how about that thank
you hope springs eternal for both the
Browns well I will have you any of these
payoff you're definitely Jonathan banks
once told you save your money
okay NFL I'm taking this and I'm placing
it in receivership I don't even know
what you've done for me Patrick I have
no idea at Patrick Fabian on Twitter
loved your work sir loved the show keep
it going thanks for watching
you got it Patrick Fabian better call
Saul Mondays at 9:00 Eastern Time on AMC
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience